Speaker 1: All right. We have shocking new
claims that are coming at a convenient time for
the person making them in order to sell books. Of
course, they always wait until it's time to sell
books. Donald Trump's brief press secretary,
Stephanie Grisham, is now making the claim
that Donald Trump deliberately had off
the books meetings to circumvent records
laws. In other words, Normal President
has meetings that are on the books
with rare exceptions for very narrow and specific
national security reasons. And there is a record
of the fact that the meetings took place. There's
records of what was discussed if the things were
classified. There is some version that does
not violate classified restrictions on topics
or documents that are brought up or whatever the
case may be. That's that's how things normally are
very rare exceptions for specific national
security reasons. Rare, very rare.
The allegation from Stephanie Grisham, which
she made on CNN. We're going to play it for you
in a moment. Is that merely to avoid there being
records of meetings that Donald Trump was having?
He had the records, the meetings off the books
and of course, in the context of Trump trying
to prevent Jan. six investigators from
getting records about who he met with
and others around Trump's circle supporting Trump
doing that. There's a second layer we have to now
contend with. If you believe Stephanie Grisham,
which is even if the meetings for which there are
records are accounted for to the investigators,
Trump allegedly was having certain meetings
off the books anyway. So there are no records
for some of these meetings. Here is Stephanie
Grisham explaining it to Jim Acosta on CNN
Speaker 3: going to keep hundreds of pages of
documents out of the hands of the January 6th
Committee. But you think that there are some
off the book meetings, some in the residence of
the White House that lawmakers may want to look
into? I mean, somebody you know that residents, as
well as most ex officials of that administration,
what goes on behind closed doors there?
Speaker 5: Absolutely. Lots of meetings take
place in the residence where, you know, I mean,
I'm hoping that they're looking at call logs, but
I have a feeling even sometimes things weren't put
into call logs. But a lot of meetings took place
because the president at the time was so paranoid
of leaks that a lot of our meetings took place
in the residence. Number one, so he could keep
track of who was in there and if it leaked out,
he would try to, you know, figure that out. But
number two, so that it was very much kept off
the books and documents, anything that was written
down could probably be thrown in the trash where
people can't, you know, come and retrieve them
to put into the archives. So that happened quite
a bit. And I'm sure the select committee is aware
of that and is looking into that. Mark Meadows was
one towards the end who was definitely helping to
plan those meetings, so I think that Mark Meadows
should be spoken to. I think he will stall.
Speaker 1: So, you know, I'm with you guys on. I'm
so glad that she has held on to that information.
Until right now, perfectly timed to sell copies of
her book, I get it. OK, I get it. But this fits
with everything else we know about Donald Trump,
a guy who claimed he would have the most.
What was it like open and transparent
administration out of anybody or something
like that? And just think like what we know
about the presidency of Trump is bad enough. There
are now things coming out that we are learning,
and they're really bad. And then there's a whole
other layer of things we probably will never
know because of things like this. There
are no records or whatever the case may be.
Remember that there's also the incredible double
standard or hypocrisy that one of the main reasons
that Donald Trump said Hillary Clinton was
unfit to be president of the United States
was she violated the Presidential Records
Act because of the private email server
and on and on and on. And and of course, we find
out that many people around Trump were also using
private email. But then we now find out all of
the different ways in which Donald Trump either
wants to prevent records from being given even
to investigators legitimately demanding them,
and even went out of his way to prevent
records from being created in the first
place. So it's all toxic. It's all insane.
It's all wacky, but it's what's going on.
And just imagine if this guy gets back into
power in 2024, how much worse it's going to be.